Here in a tranquil and secluded rural setting,
Benjamin Harnwell's mission is to establish
a training center in a former monastery here
in Trisulti....an academy with extremely conservative
outlooks.
With his so-called Institute for Human Dignity,
Harnwell has set himself an ambitious goal
– to save Western Civilization, mobilizing
Christians and Jews in the fight against Islam
as he refers to religious role models for
his mission.
"This depiction here behind me is the martyrdom
of Saint Bartholomew.
He was skinned alive for his beliefs in Jesus
Christ.
You've got to remember that today in the world
Christianity is the world's most persecuted
religion.
We often forget that in the West."
The academy aims to train budding young politicians
to become staunch Catholics and right-wing
populists.
"Trisulti in the next generation is going
to become the global headquarters of the fight
to defend the Judeo-Christian basis of Western
Civilization, not just here in Europe but
right across the world."
The Catholics seem to look on Steve Bannon
as the ideal partner for the project -- Donald
Trump's former chief strategist regularly
meets with Hartwell in Rome.
They first met when Bannon ran the ultra conservative
Breitbart News website.
Bannon is enthusiastic about Harnwell's project.
"I'm just honored he's asked me to help out,
and what I'm trying to do is add maybe a little
organizational ability and bring in donors,
faculty people I know throughout the world
that can teach."
Bannon wants to bring together populist and
identitarian forces in Italy and other European
countries.
A patronage by conservative Catholics suits
his cause very well.
He also has his eye on next month's European
Parliament elections.
"That's what their fear is, because the populist
nationalist sovereignty movement has great
politicians, a great message, and now it has
traction.
And that's why it's on the cusp, maybe, if
the momentum keeps, through Spain and other
nations, a stunning victory in May."
For Bannon, the academy should become an ideal
breeding ground for his crusaders.
Among its backers are ultra-conservative circles
within the Vatican -- who reject Pope Francis's
liberal calls for inclusion and support for
immigrants.
The American Cardinal Raymond Leo Burke is
head of the board of advisers of the Institute
in Trisulti.
He has openly endorsed Donald Trump's conservative
agenda in the United States.
Critics see the emergence as an unholy alliance
that will seek to use Trisulti to undermine
pluralist democratic societies, led by arch-conservative
Catholics who rely on the help of political
agitators like Steve Bannon.
"What they have in common is this obsessive
cult of identity.
They say: We represent Christendom, Western
Civilization, Europe, founded on Judeo-Christian
values, and we are being invaded, so we must
defend ourselves."
Many local residents in Trisulti have launched
protests -- they don't want Steve Bannon and
far-right populists here.
The monastery is a religious site, both a
place of pilgrimage and a tourist attraction.
They want the government to rescind the lease
on the property.
"Why is a local monastery being used for an
ideological project?
Trisulti will become the launchpad for a movement.
Just look at its ideas, its sources of finance,
and its goals!"
Benjamin Harnwell remains confident.
The lease is valid, he says.
The plans to start operations are in place.
What can stop him and Bannon now?
"Culture is upstream of politics, and that's
where we're working at.
So I think anything we're going to do will
help Matteo Salvini and any of the populist
nationalist movements in Europe or around
the world."
Harnwell's plans seem clear: Trisulti should
become a launching pad for far-right populists
to take over Europe . One that can count on
the blessing of arch-conservative Catholic
clerics in high places.
The academy aims to start its first courses this summer.
But before that it remains to be seen
how well the nationalists and populists perform
in the European elections in May.